[Musique]
c'est la première fois que vous venez en
croatie et je te manquait pas mon âge
amusez vous bien une foire et à profiter
de la vie
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
vous avez perdu quelque chose
m'est arrivé quelque chose cette nuit là
je suis certaine bonne chance
voilà
m me ferais pas un truc pareil il faut
que tu compteras la maison
comment j'ai pas pu le voir
on ne voit généralement que ce qu'on a
envie de voir
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à croire qu'on soit ici
week end autre fille avec sa meilleure
amie
alors nous éclater comme dans notre
folle jeunesse qui sait quand on pourra
le refaire
pas
etc
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous avez
perdu quelque chose
on a mis plusieurs personnes vous ont vu
vous disputez qualité vous mais je suis
marié parent est soit pas aussi coincé
c'est totalement faux je croyais que
vous ne vous souvenez absolument pas de
cette soirée
votre histoire change tout le temps
il faut que tu rentres à la maison c'est
impossible rabat la police a pris mon
passeport donné on doit vite partir
il y a autre chose que vous ne nous avez
pas encore dit
[Musique]